>> Laura: IT'S FRIDAY AND THAT
MEANS IT'S TIME FOR FRIDAY
FOLLIES, COME ON.
YOU KNOW BY NOW.
UNCLE JOE DOESN'T KNOW WHEN TO
LET IT GO.
AOC SPORTING A NEW ACCENT AND
VIDEO THAT WILL MAKE OUR MALE
VIEWERS CRINGE.
JOINING US WITH ALL THE DETAILS.
A POWER, RAYMOND, JOE BIDEN
SPOKE PUBLICLY AT THE HINCKLEY
HILTON  DA, I UNDERSTAND.
>> HE WAS SPEAKING AT THE
INTERNATIONAL BROTHERHOOD OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS IN D.C.
THE PRESIDENT OF THAT UNION,
LONNIE STEVENSON, INTRODUCED
THE FORMER VICE PRESIDENT WITH
A HUG.
>> I JUST WANT YOU TO KNOW I
HAD PERMISSION TO HUG LONNIE.
ALL THOSE KIDS, YOU WANT TO
COME UP ON THE STAGE, YOU CAN
COME UP.
IT'S OKAY.
I HAVE TO STAND ALL WRONG BUT
BY THE WAY, HE GAVE ME
PERMISSION TO TOUCH HIM.
>> LAURA, SOME COMMENTATORS ARE
FURIOUS ABOUT WHAT -- THAT
BIDEN WOULD DARE TO JOKE ABOUT
THE HUG AND SNIFF GATE.
LOOK AT THIS.
>> IT WASN'T FUNNY.
MAKING LIGHT OF IT?
SORT OF -- I DON'T NOE, LEAVES
ME SCRATCHING MY HEAD.
>> THE FACT THAT HE JOKED ABOUT
IT TODAY IS A PROBLEM.
>> HE DOESN'T GET IT.
>> I SUSPECT A LOT OF OTHER
PEOPLE ESPECIALLY THE WOMEN
INVOLVED WILL FIND OFFENSIVE.
>> Laura: OH JOHN, OH JOHN,
COME ON.
YOU ARE NOT WOKE ENOUGH TO HAVE
A SENSE OF HUMOR.
HE IS OF A DIFFERENT GENERATION.
>> I AGREE WITH YOU ENTIRELY.
>> Laura: THE LEFT HAS LOT ANY
SENSE OF HUMOR.
>> PEOPLE ON THE RIGHT HAVE THE
TORCHES  NOOSES OUT FOR JOE
BIDEN.
>> MY GRANDFATHER WOULD HUG AND
GRAB PEOPLE BY THE FACE.
BUT HE WAS BEING AFFECTIONATE.
IT WAS HIS GENERATION.
>> Laura: I THINK WE SHOULD
WALK AROUND WITH BUBBLE WRAP,
HELLO, HOW ARE YOU?
I'LL TEXT YOU LATER.
>> "THE NEW YORK TIMES" SAID
THERE SHOULD BE 18 INCHES AND
THREE TO FOUR INCHES.
I WOULD HAVE TO BE 12 FEET AWAY
FROM YOU.
HELLO, LAURA.
>> Laura: YOU ARE IN MY SPACE.
>> I HAVE TO GET TO THIS.
AT REVEREND AL'S CONVENTION
TODAY.
>> Laura: IS THAT NANCY
PELOSI'S CONVENTION.
>> NATIONAL ACTION NETWORK.
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ WAS
TRYING OUT A NEW ACCENT.
>> THE FIGHT HAS BEEN LONG,
Y'ALL, THIS IS WHAT ORGANIZING
LOOKS LIKE.
THIS IS WHAT BUILDING POWER
I'M PROUD TO BE A BARTENDER.
AIN'T NOTHING WRONG WITH THAT.
>> THERE MAY BE SOMETHING WRONG
WITH THAT.
AOC SEEMS LIKE SHE IS TRYING
OUT THIS NEW AFRICAN-AMERICAN
SOUTHERN ACCENT.
SHE HAS GOTTEN A LOW OF
BLOWBACK.
SHE SAID I'M FROM THE BRONX.
I ACT AND TALK LIKE IT WHEN I'M
FIRED UP.
THAT DOESN'T EXACTLY SOUND LIKE
QUEENS TO ME.
>> Laura: THE BRONX AIN'T
QUEENS, OKAY.
I'M NOT GETTING THAT.
IS AIN'T -- NO WAY, REMIND ME
OF -- WAIT, I KNOW WAY --
>> I DON'T FEEL NO WAY TIRED.
I COME TOO FAR.
FROM WHERE I STARTED FROM.
NOBODY TOLD ME THAT THE ROAD
WOULD BE EASY.
>> SOMEBODY SHOULD REMIND THESE
WOMEN ALL AFRICAN-AMERICANS ARE
NOT BENEATH THE MASON DIXON
LINE AND EVERY TIME YOU ARE IN
FRONT OF AN AFRICAN-AMERICAN
AUDIENCE YOU DON'T HAVE TO TRY
TO AFFECT THIS VERY ODD.
BE YOURSELF.
>> Laura: SHE SAID THIS IS THE
WAY WE TALK OR I TALK?
WE'VE BEEN PLAYING SOUND BITES
FOR HER.
>> REMEMBER WHEN SHE SAID THIS
ON A RADIO SHOW ?AO
>> I CARRY HOT SAUCE.
>> PEOPLE WILL SAY OKAY, SHE IS
PANDERING TO BLACK PEOPLE AGAIN.
[LAUGHTER]
>> OKAY.
>> IS IT WORKING?
>> THAT'S THE LINE.
THIS IS OBVIOUS PANDERING TO
THE CROWD YOU'RE IN FRONT OF.
IT IS SHAME F *U.
>> Laura: SHE WAS TREATED LIKE
A ROCK STAR.
SHE WALKED IN AND GOT MORE
APPLAUSE THAN BETO.
KAMALA HARRIS STARTS LAUGHING.
NO ONE HAS MADE A JOKE.
AOC WALKS OUT.
SHE OWNED THAT HOUSE.
SHE DID A GOOD JOB WITH THAT
SPEECH.
>> THIS NEXT BIT OF VIDEO COULD
BE CALLED FRIDAY FOLLIES.
THIS POOR GUY WAS REMOVING A
TREE WHEN THINGS WENT WRONG.
IT IS A REMINDER WHEN YOU CUT
DOWN A TREE, MIND WHERE YOU ARE
STANDING.
MEN, YOU'VE BEEN WARNED.
>> OH.
>> Laura: WE HAVE TO SAY
>> HE IS ALL RIGHT BUT IT BEGS
THE QUESTION WHEN A PROSTATE
FALLS IN THE FOREST CAN IT GET
UP AGAIN?
I HURT WHEN I SAW THAT.
I WAS THINKING ABOUT JOE BIDEN,
THINKING THROUGH THE PAIN.
WHAT WE REALLY PERHAPS NEED ARE
PRE-HUG CONSENT DECREES.
I'VE BEEN DOING THESE PRE-HUG
CONSENT DEGREES, IN CASE OF A
FUNERAL OR SCHOOL EVENT,
GRADUATION OR JOE BIDEN'S HOUSE
YOU GET A PRE-CONSENT TO HUG
PEOPLE.
I'VE BEEN GETTING PEOPLE TO
SIGN THEM ALL DAY LONG AT FOX.
OH, THANK YOU.
I DON'T NEED YOU TO SIGN IT.
I HAVE PLENTY OF THEM.
>> Laura: YOU WERE ALLOWED TO
HUG?